hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play an exit by sky
midnight this is the same guy that made
scp-432 and if you could tell by the
intro sequence it looks pretty dang good
goal try to find exit I like this I
think that this is actually the menu
wait hang on no never go never go back
haha ah
what is that I'm not going back I'm
sorry I was looking backwards then I
went forward times oh sorry okay jumping
right into it okay so hahaha this is a
recent more recent game that he has
developed that I am looking at and
judging by what I'm seeing so far oh
well that doesn't help me very much
let's go right oh man the only objective
is to try to find an exit you're lost in
this place
okay oh man I said before when I was
playing scp-432 which was his other game
that the atmosphere was very good if the
AI of the monster was just a little
questionable but
man oh man I can never go back
this is ridiculously awesome amazing job
guy huh oh I don't know what that face
was in the beginning
oh no no oh
is something gonna come kill me I can I
can't go back hmm
okay um okay seems to be okay everything
seems to be hunky-dory
oh no no no am I just stuck here oh that
is so insane oh man does anything happen
oh man oh I don't think anything's gonna
happen but it would be so cool if
something did that might be something to
add just a little look crucifer there I
don't know what that face was in the
beginning but I guess I got a hit escape
and restart whoops oh boy all right take
two BAM
so like like with the other one I think
this might be this might be the final
version I'm not exactly sure I can't
remember what the version was that I
downloaded but this is just a very
interesting game it's a different take
on our games which are usually find
object a or get object B's you know it's
just very standard ha ha ha yeah
what is that what is that what is that
what are you oh my god George Oh what
are you yeah yeah yeah that was him
callous monster I should have yeah I
should have seen that long timeyou
Bobbitt
ha ha stop that
ok so I don't know if this is randomly
generated or all the same which means
that probably like scp-432 it's static
environment which is okay it just means
I gotta keep trying until I find the
exit is that thing still there
no what was that thing I don't even know
what it was what was it let's go this
way
yeah right ha ha I wonder if that
floating skull is supposed to be the
monster that was supposed to kill me
once I got to a dead end
what
who's got up
okay all right all right okay okay I'll
go gamble Gallagher
okay I'll the kid just came over for
nothing bad is gonna happen nothing I
don't have a sprint or anything so I'm
totally oh god oh oh if I had one thing
that I would definitely change about
this game it's that after that happens
definitely just stop it stop it
definitely just have something come and
kill you when you get back to the X on
the other side that would be perfect
other than that this game is incredible
I mean it's so damn terrifying oh you
guys have got to try this for yourself
links obviously in the description below
where it always is plan try it do this
please do this I don't want to be here
alone let's try going this way this time
I don't like to be lone
aha
and if I did I think I mentioned it but
this one is made on the unity engine
where the last game I think was made on
the FPS creator if I'm not mistaken
again there's that noise
I think that's his party I'm bad
never go back how am i back in the
beginning that's impossible
huh never go back
stop it what how did I get back to the
beginning how how I don't even know okay
all right then I somehow went back so
take that game ha broke you good no I
don't know I don't know ha
okay I don't remember which way I went
what I went this way so I've just got to
go a random direction of which however
where Lulu I think I went straight I'll
go right no I I wait no I think I went
right I'm not sure anymore top it this
game with mother with my mind the noises
I got the sound turned up way in my
headphones it it's just like an course
of nah that's not possible
that's not possible that is not not not
possible how oh ah this game it got
quiet okay there comes again okay loop
back in I thought nothing worried
simples gonna happen there aren't that
many monsters in this besides that skull
the weird skull okay let's go right
again I guess I just tried on to find my
way back
you mother oh no oh no oh God he went
away you went away oh I'm not gonna get
any sleep tonight
not gonna get any bleep tonight okay
all right okay just keep going straight
straights gotta be it
Reds gotta be in maybe I don't know
maybe probably be keep going straight
off fudge this way good enough oh oh oh
okay don't go that way
oh this is such a dead end I know it I
got feel it I feel this is a dead end
this is gonna be a dead end I know this
I do these things or somehow someway I'm
gonna be looped back the beginning
I don't know I don't know I don't know
nope no wha hey keep going straight
straights done good for me so far off
balls how that white what Oh Zell the
way out oh god baby I don't know
please baby baby baby baby mama mama
baby be the way out I don't know ah ah
ah dadadada
please please please please don't be a
trick
hey don't be a drink I don't want it to
be a trick I want to go home I want to
go home
oh it looks so nice the white light go
towards the light oh it's getting
brighter in here I can almost see it oh
that's rust that's got blood on the
walls
oh it's rust well oh no no oh I'm not
playing anymore
oh well that was a little cheesy that
was kind of a cheesy out rate movie ha
ha ha
but anyway that was great that was
really good but um it could use a little
work on the monster interaction but as
far as atmosphere in the gameplay oh it
was incredible I felt so perfect and it
was claustrophobic and everything it was
great I loved every bit of it so thank
you all so much for watching thanks sky
midnight for making another cool game
keep it up you're doing great um click
the link in the description for the
download so you can play for yourselves
leave a comment for him or me to let me
know what you or me cuz I think he keeps
watching my videos so he should probably
comment at some point on this video so
thank you all someone for watching click
the end today's more videos it I've done
and as always I will
you in the next video bye bye he just so
happened at that time he was right in
front hi TIA
Oh what are you always coming
he's like a go kick cuts right through
the wall that's not even fair look at
him